[Music]
what are you doing here nice guy yeah
hang on
Indiana Jones back in the saddle get
back
the dial could change the course of
history
fasten your seatbelt looking for this oh
my life
for the PG-13
we love Indiana Jones because we love
movies The Joy of those Adventures we
love the cause and effect the tripwire
of events all these pieces fit together
to make the lighting in a bottle of an
Indiana Jones film but also It just fits
Harrison like a glove
preparation was not really necessary
Harrison loves this character as much as
the audience loves this character so we
ask ourselves what could be the next
adventure and in this case it was what
could be the last adventure we come to
find him in 1969 the world has changed
around him he's retiring as a professor
and he's about to stumble into an
adventure sorry
it's filled with awe and excitement and
danger and they've completely captured
that
[Music]
I felt good
and that we had made a film
that the audience deserved
I feel confident that we're gonna knock
their socks off
I've been looking for this all my life
[Music]
oh
hell Indiana Jones
[Music]
[Applause]